No wonder everybody wants to be active
in that month. Now we know why. Subhan
Allah. Dr. Zakia, um, are there any
particular activities a Muslim should
concentrate upon during this blessed
month of Ramadan? And of course, we
should relate to you the importance of
the fact that our viewers really can
gain massive benefit by knowing specific
activities they can get involved in and
they can start planning the Ramadan now.
>> Yes, I believe that this is a very good
question because most of the activities
we'll be dealing as time goes on in the
episode. But just to give a brief
outline, I will just specify a few
important because the whole answer will
take very long. The few important points
that will be noted is that number one it
is the nia. The nia is very important.
The nia of fasting should only be for
Allah subhana wa t'ala and for a fasting
to be accepted the na is important. So
making the na is very important without
which the fasting will not be accepted.
Number two is observing the sunnah of
the fast
that we'll be dealing in detail in the
next few days. But just a point to be
noted that one of the important sunnah
is that we should have sur
as late as possible that is just before
the break of dawn just before faj salah
and we should break our fast havear as
early as possible immediately after
sunset.
Furthermore, in this blessed month, we
should be careful and
we should avoid all things which are
prohibited, which are haram and all
things which are makru. And this is the
best opportunity where a person if he
has certain activities which are against
the Sharia whether he's doing haram
activities or makra activities this is
the best time he can abstain from it and
that will be a good habit which
inshallah he may abstain maybe
throughout his life. For example, if a
person has habituated to drinking
alcohol, if he can abstain from having
alcohol from the break of dawn to
sunset, he can abstain from it from the
cradle to the grave. Similarly, we
should take care that we should abstain
from the things which are makru.
For example, it is makru to stand and
drink water. And if you have to do that
so see to it that in this month of
Ramadan while having water we should sit
down. This was the sunnah of the
prophet. So it's a good month in which
you can abstain from the haram
activities which you have been doing
maybe some of them or the makur
activities. Furthermore
it's a good time where you can implement
many of the sunnah of the prophet in
your day-to-day life. For example maybe
sporting a beard.
Many Muslims don't have a beard. So it's
a good month where you can follow the
sunnah of the prophet. The sunnah of the
prophet about the duas of when you enter
the home, when you leave the toilet, the
dua that is there when you're traveling
in a vehicle.
So this is a good month in which you can
adopt as much as sunnah as possible so
that we can be on the straight path.
This is a very good month where you
should see to it that you should offer
the salah not only the five time salah
which is the fur even try and offer as
many naw and sunnah
and if you're not habituated to reading
in congregation see to the reading
congregation and as far as possible go
to the mosque for the salah in this
month we should be particular that we do
not miss the tawi many people think and
it is a fact that is a sunnah But many
people think that because it's a sunnah
we can miss tarawi. Tarawi is a very
important sunnah though it's not a fur
but every Muslim should make it a point
that as far as possible they should
attend tarawi because of the blessings
it has. So taravi is very important
which Muslims should never miss.
And when we offer taravi, many of us we
rush through taravi because we want to
complete the Quran and many of them read
the taravi 100 miles per hour. We should
read the taravi with patience at a
moderate pace so that people can
understand what is the commandment of
Allah subhanaa tala
and that if time permits and if possible
we should try and do in the last 10 days
and while doing make it a point that we
don't socialize many people make a
mistake of socializing during the whole
purpose of is defeated
furthermore we should do more da in this
month we should do more supplications
this is the month of dua
and
we should do more zikar spend time in
remembering Allah subhana wa ta'ala and
also worshiping him this is the month in
which we should try and read as much as
Quran as possible besides reciting the
Quran Arabic if you know Arabic as a
language then there's no problem but if
you don't know then also read the
translation of the Quran in the language
we understand the best if If you
understand English, read it in English.
If you understand udu, read udu, read it
in the language you understand the best.
But while it's in the Quran for which
you get a saw, also read the translation
of the Quran so that you can implement
on the guidance of Allah subhana wa
ta'ala. If possible, read the Quran once
in every seven days or at least read
one every day so that you complete the
Quran at least once in the full month of
Ramadan. In this month try and read as
much as had possible but see to it that
you read the authentic hadith
and the best book on hadith is the book
of say bkari then is say Muslim you can
read the other also but read authentic
books on hadith read books on the
lifestyle and the of the prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
See to it that if you have not given the
zakat please give the zakat which is an
obligatory charity
and every rich person who has a saving
of more than the nisab level more than
85 g of gold he or she should give 2.5%
of his saving every lunar charity that
is zakat and many people they do not
calculate the zakat properly you make it
a point that you calculate the zakat
honestly and it It was better to give a
little bit more rather than to give
less.
So calculate it properly and see to it
that you give your zakat. And this
Ramadan is a month of generosity. It's a
month of satka and you get 10 times more
reward for good deeds. So this is a
month where you should do maximum
charity
and besides that we should make it a
point that during this month we should
be cheerful. Many of the Muslims they
look dull, they look gloomy. You should
be cheerful and happy and we should give
more time to our family. Many times we
neglect our family. It is seed that we
give more time to our family and do all
these activities collectively.
We should also have saloo to the people
around you. That means we should deal
with the other human beings with mercy,
with love, with care. If they have done
some mistakes that forgive them this is
a month of forgiveness. If you have done
something wrong to them ask for
forgiveness
live with the people around you with
love, care and with affection.
We should to that means ponder
on the things. See to it that you plan
your month of Ramadan.
Plan it properly and see to it that you
do not waste not even a minute, not even
a second. This is a month of gaining
and this month is the best month for
self-improvement also
and besides that should also make it a
point to do Islah
with your other Muslim brothers and
sisters.
It's also the best month to do dawa that
is convey the message of Islam to the
non-Muslims.
So it's my request to the brothers and
sisters that plan your month efficiently
and see to it that you utilize every
second of this blessed month.